so the heading is keeping identities and
in order to make sense of what we need
to talk a little bit about 100
identities on because you may have heard
this word turn around a little bit I
actually mentioned it this year already
prepackaged and by DC I mean this week
but now is the time to properly think
about it let's make a stop in algebra so
far actually ever since you've learnt
algebra way back in year 7 we've learnt
about a bunch of different kinds of
power to break objects now where we
began was with expressions an algebraic
expression is basically when you've got
some algebra and or some numbers throw
it in together and there a theme so for
example 2a plus 7 thank you
it's about algebra in it it's an
algebraic expression and it's an object
I can keep that on its own window give
factorizing the expressions so far so
you'll get you know the collection of
items you put them together by the way
those items each individual thing the 2a
and then the 7 what do we call those
start with the teeth turns very good so
you've got here the two terms right so I
guess we would call this a binomial
expression because by means to know
means consuming that's where we get the
word name from she got two objects there
you've got these two terms are made of
lots of different things that letter a
what do we call that again I'm pruning
rule the thing attached to the
pronumeral starting to see the
coefficient and then lastly along the
end the 7 there is a constant we call it
a constant because
it doesn't change its value doesn't
change now I will point out this a this
a could also be a constant I actually
don't know if it were constant what
would we call it starts with a V if it
doesn't stay closed that it could change
which means it's variable okay pretty
much can be either we know some pretty
famous constants that we designate the
protocol like say this guy a couple of
days ago I mentioned this guy and
there's lots of others where even though
we've got a pruning rule there we
actually mean a specific number that
never changes okay in this case we don't
know how do I turn an expression like
this into an equation then in takers
yeah okay fantastic I'm gonna take this
we should all have this on the Border's
on that page as well and you just make
it equal to anything and our suggestion
was zero that's pretty common but you
can make it equal to negative three or a
on two pi or a so long as there is an
equals sign it's an equation okay so far
so good
and we're already on spoke very briefly
about making sure we don't confuse those
two factorizing and expression is quite
distinct and different from solving an
equation okay you can't solve an
expression right there's no value this
it could be any implement whereas an
equation eight only has one now what
value is it in this case in this case I
think it's negative three and a half
isn't it now by the way just a minor
aside just cuz I heard you say it I do
mean negative three and a half not minus
three and a half what's the difference
between minus and [ __ ] don't know
whereas like in between things being
comfortable something and wires okay so
I'm gonna try and be a little more
specific there - is an operation - it's
a verb it does something something -
something else whereas negative is not a
verb it's not an action what kind of
word is negative it's it's an adjective
it describes something else right now we
kind of throw these around
interchangeably because we more or less
use the same symbol for both them
however I wonder how many of you get
calculator out to calculate
I don't know how many of you realized
this but I'm going to draw this in a
second there is actually a negative
button on your calculator and I bet
you've never used it okay on my
calculator and most people have one it's
the same just above the recall button
RCL just above that like that what's
that guy doing
this guy here now there's a good reason
and a bad reason why this poor locally
button is and sitting there never used
on your calculator I'll get one servers
a little bit later on when we actually
start to talk about these I just want
you to have that triggered at your brain
all right now what if we say the
difference between an expression and
equation was what was the difference
it's just the equal sign that's it
that's all the differences so therefore
what's the difference between an
equation and what I would call an
identity now we've only sort of throwing
this row around a couple of times and
I've never dealt with it in detail
that's why I'm doing it now I'm going to
give you an identity I'll give you an
example what I want you to write it down
and then I want you to think what is it
that distinguishes what I'm about to
write over here with one of these
because they'll look quite similar
okay so here's one I'm gonna pick one
that you already know with W history PR
is an identity now you may say looks
like has all the ingredients of an
equation and I would say to that well
this equation looks like it has all the
ingredients of an expression right so
there's something the equation has which
the expression does have and that makes
a special different and there's
something that this identity has that
the equation doesn't have but wonder
what the difference is any suggestions
any thoughts and I'm open to lots of
Romans because Romans are where you
learn something Eric what do you think
okay so he gets it in one let's think
about this this is why I drew out the
fact that a could only have one value
over here for the equation right this
equation is true sometimes actually it's
only true one time right but we've seen
equations that are true multiple times
this equation this equation is true
twice right and those values that x
equals negative 2 and x equals negative
3 so it's true sometimes but lots of the
time it's not true right whereas this
here which is also an equation is more
than an equation because no matter what
value of a or b you throw in there it is
always true every single time okay so
what do we got here an expression an
expression cannot be true or false just
like the word dog cannot be true or
false it's like well there's no isn't a
value statement there like is this right
or wrong it's nothing it's just an
expression an equation can be true or
false it's true sometimes
then I will point out you can also write
equation that is never true but I'll get
onto those later I usually do that by
accident okay
lastly an identity is not true sometimes
it's true always
irrespective of the values that you saw
either right
so later on this turn for example we're
not going to have a look at how to break
identities we're gonna have a look at
trigonometric identities and they're
things like this that they're true no
matter what Able's you put in in no
matter what values anything you like or
waitress now just to indicate this
occasionally but frequently not
occasionally you'll say rather than
being written with an equal sign
mathematicians may want to point out the
fact and highlight the fact that hey
this is this is like more than the
equation it's always true so sometimes
they'll put in a third bar now you
recognize that symbol you say before
right what does it mean Congress right
and the word codes means the same right
you take those two triangles you can
flip them around row flip them there's
still the same triangle no matter what
and that's the same idea that's got out
here so make sense